as the grandson of a migrant I have no
difficulty saying that migrants can very
often make a very viable contribution to
the country that that receives them that
is uh very straightforward I want to
concentrate my opening remarks on the
question of Asylum Seekers and the
current crisis which involves not
hundreds or even tens of thousands but
millions of people who are entitled to
think of themselves as refugees seeking
Asylum some of the facts are not
controversial it is not controversial
that people have a right under
international law to seek Asylum if they
are being persecuted secondly it's not
in dispute there are several million
people mostly syrians but not just
syrians who can claim that entitlement
at the present time
and I think thirdly also I have no
problem with the proposition that the
United Kingdom and Europe must accept a
share of the obligation to meet that
requirement but let me move into
slightly more controversial territory
the first point I would make is that the
vast majority of the Syrian Asylum
Seekers are no longer in Syria there are
many who are in Syria but I'm talking
about the two or three million perhaps
even more than that who are mainly in
turkey or Jordan or Lebanon and at this
moment in time they are no longer
suffering uh persecution that has made
them Asylum Seekers they have Asylum
although not in very agreeable or
attractive circumstances and with no
certainty as to their long-term future
but they are not currently
at risk to their lives because of the
government and the country from which
they have left second point people have
rights of seeking Asylum
they neither have nor have ever had a
right to say and I want to go to this
particular country and it's unreasonable
and unacceptable for that country not to
accept me there is no such legal
entitlement that is a matter for both
the receiving country and the Asylum
Seeker to reach agreement on and thirdly
there is no specific British or european
obligation that doesn't apply to the
rest of the world
the treaty obligations we all operate
under are Universal obligations and
therefore if there are millions of
people seeking Asylum this is not as
it's so often described a challenge to
Europe it is an ethical and legal
obligation for all the Civilized
countries of the world to share in
responding to this burden and the final
point I would make in these opening
comments is in addition to that there is
a very real question as to whether the
best way when you're dealing with
millions of people who are living very
close to their original country
many of whom will want to return to that
country most of whom are actually of
these refugees are exactly the sort of
people their own country needs even more
than the rest of the world because of
their professional skills and their
other educated qualities we have to also
look at ways of allowing them to remain
as close as possible to Syria which will
require billions billions of pounds or
dollars of help from the International
Community but enable and also a change
in the rules that at the moment prevents
them even being able to work when you're
living as a refugee and an asylum Seeker
that is absurd and obviously it causes
maximum discontent so there are a remedy
of solutions but I conclude by saying it
is not either ethically or legally
correct to imply that there is a
uniquely British obligation or european
obligation all the past problems such as
at the end of the second world war led
to millions of people going not just a
year elsewhere in Europe but to the
United States to South America to
Australia and in the case of Arab
refugees the Arab states themselves many
of whom are incredibly wealthy should be
accepting their share of the obligation
also